today we're going to get into what it's
like to make measurements
on quantum mechanical objects in our
previous lecture we talked about the two
slit experiment
which is actually a set of experiments
that reveals the wave nature of tiny
objects
and now in this lecture we'll start to
see how that wave character kind of
messes with our experimental setups and
tends to present us
with some strange paradoxes
i'll even show you how it is that in the
quantum world you could sit
in three chairs at once and this is very
important
anybody who's ever been on a date to a
movie theater knows how critical this
is my husband and i have been married
for over 25 years and we still struggle
with this one
you know how it goes you enter the movie
theater and your date asks you
where do you want to sit well the only
right answer to that is
i want to sit wherever you want to sit
right and then you end up sitting where
neither of you wants to sit
so if we could figure this one out we
could solve a lot of issues and help a
lot of people
to help us understand how measurements
go in quantum mechanics
imagine that you're a scientist in a
laboratory
and you need to make some measurements
on a particle
now to help us think about that imagine
that we're in a universe where quantum
effects are large enough that we can
observe them in our everyday experience
there's actually a parameter a constant
of nature which controls the strength of
quantum
effects and it's called the planck
constant
in our universe the value of the planck
constant is small enough that quantum
effects
don't become obvious until we observe
things on
tiny length scales typically about the
size of an atom or smaller
however if we lived in a universe where
the planck constant was a much
larger number we could more directly
experience
some of the incredible effects of
quantum mechanics that we are able to
measure
in the lab so let's imagine that there's
some knob we can turn
to make the plank constant big enough so
that we can experience quantum effects
ourselves without the need for any
special equipment
now imagine you're sitting in your
living room which is now a
quantum living room and there's a
particle in there
that you need to measure let's further
suppose that
there's a ficus tree in the room and
that the particle is sitting
on that tree we're visualizing this as a
particle but
any time we speak only in terms of
particles or even
only in terms of waves that is an
approximation
the quantum object is really both at the
same time
it just is so there's a particle in
our quantum living room and it's in the
on the tree state
a state is whatever the particle happens
to be doing
right now it's on the tree so we see
it's in the
on the tree state now
what do you think the wave underlying
that state
should look like remember that quantum
mechanical waves
wiggle more in places where you're more
likely to find the particle
and in this case our particle is sitting
in the tree
so the wave underlying the on the tree
state is going to be
flat everywhere in the quantum living
room except for in the tree
in other words you should envision a
wave that is flat lined in most parts of
the quantum living room
but then it's wiggling there in the
ficus tree before going flat again
outside of the tree
so this is how you make a wave that
corresponds to the
on the tree state it's wiggling in the
tree
so when you go to look for the particle
you're going to find it in the tree
okay so far now we could put the
particle somewhere else
in the quantum living room for example
let's move the particle onto the quantum
couch we would say that now it's in a
state called the
on the couch state because what's it
doing it's
sitting on the couch now think about
what the wave
underlying and on the couch state should
look like
well that wave must be flat lined
everywhere in the quantum living room
and then it wiggles a little bit on the
couch and then it quits wiggling
so that where the wave wiggles most
that's where you're most likely to find
the particle
when you go to look for it
maybe you don't yet know where the
particle is and you need to find it
so to do that you're going to make
what's called a position
measurement you would measure the
particle's position
in order to find out where it is now
if you knew the shape of the wave you
would already know where the particle is
and you'd be done but it turns out that
we can't
measure the wave directly and this is a
huge problem in quantum mechanics
it accounts for a lot of the
difficulties that we encounter
both in trying to make these
measurements and especially in trying to
interpret them
if we can measure the wave directly we
would know everything there is to know
about the particle
all at once we would know its position
and its energy and
anything else we might need to know
but we don't actually have the ability
to measure the wave
directly and as far as we know this is a
fundamental
limitation we don't foresee ever being
able to directly measure the quantum
wave
itself so that means when we make
measurements in the laboratory
we have to be creative it's a little bit
like asking the particle
a question such as where are you
the answer to that question would be the
particle's position
now here's another important key to
understanding quantum physics
the laws of quantum mechanics are such
that
only certain allowable answers happen to
our questions
that's another way of saying that only
certain answers are allowed
when we take a measurement in fact
this is where the word quantum comes
back in
in lecture one we talked about how the
word quantum
comes from the word quantized which
means countable
we talked about how certain things in
your everyday life are quantized as
well like the number of unopened soda
cans in
your refrigerator or the number of
people in a room
you can't have three and a half unopened
sodapop cans
in your refrigerator that's just not
possible so
the question how many unopened soda cans
do we have
that's an example of a question which
has only certain allowable
answers and the answers in between just
are not
possible now just like
unopened soda cans particles are
quantized
the upshot is that when we make our
measurements of a particle
there will only be certain answers that
it can give us
when we ask it what it's doing when we
ask for its
state it's a little bit like being given
a bad
form to fill out in real life maybe
you've had this experience of filling
out a form that asks you to mark your
ethnicity and there are these little
check boxes that don't quite give the
full picture
but the form asks you to check just one
box
well that doesn't work for most people
right but in the case of quantum
particles they really are
stuck checking boxes that correspond
to the measurements that we make
so what are measurements like
measurements happen
in a laboratory we have big pieces of
equipment that interact with
the little quantum objects and then the
big pieces of equipment display
numbers that we read off and we call
that a measurement
and we get to measure things like energy
position
velocity speed those sorts of properties
now back to our quantum living room and
we'll use the example of the wave that
wiggles at the couch
if i took a measurement on this type of
wave
with a big piece of equipment that's
designed to measure
the position of the particle that's kind
of like asking the particle
hey where are you in this case the
particle would have to reply
i'm on the couch that's the only answer
that it can
give because there's no probability of
finding the particle
anywhere except where its wave is
wiggling
and it's only wiggling on the couch
therefore when you ask it where are you
it's going to have to say
i'm on the couch and now
what do you think would happen if you
were to repeat the exact
same measurement right away it turns out
there's no funny business yet
you'll get exactly what you expect in
this case
the prior measurement that we made left
the particle
in a pure position state
the particle remains in that position
state in between measurements and then
if we take the measurement again we'll
get exactly the same
answer in short the particle stays on
the couch
to recap when we make a measurement it's
like asking the particle a question
about what it's doing and the particle
must return an answer that corresponds
to a
pure state of the question being asked
in this case we took a position
measurement so
the particle had to give an answer in
terms of position
and then subsequent measurements of
position
return the same answer that we got
before
so far none of this seems too strange
but don't worry we'll get to some of the
strange stuff pretty soon
in the example we just went through we
asked our quantum particle
where it was and it answered i'm on the
couch
now we know it's in the on the couch
state had the particle been sitting on
the ficus tree
instead then when we made a measurement
of position
it would have replied i'm in the tree
and we would have known at that point
that it was in the
on the tree state these are examples
of pure states of position
if particles were always in pure states
quantum mechanics would be easier
and it wouldn't give us so many strange
answers
unfortunately particles are really that
simple
instead they often exist in mixed states
rather than pure states
and mixed states are part of what gives
us some of the strange behavior
each particle has a wave associated with
it
because of the nature of waves the wave
can take
any shape it wants to take so
let's picture a wave shape where the
wave is flat lined
everywhere except it's wiggling a little
bit on the couch
and it's wiggling a little bit in the
tree
what i've done is something called a
superposition
superposition is a fancy word that means
i added them together
so i'm going to stick together the two
states we had before
in such a way that the wave is wiggling
more on the couch
than it is on the tree this is a thought
experiment so we can make
anything we like let's say we make it
seventy percent on the couch and
thirty percent in the tree
waves can do that there's no problem
with that given its wave properties a
quantum mechanical particle has
no problem wiggling its wave a little
bit over here
and also wiggling it a little bit over
there
so right now where is the particle
there's still just one particle that's
very important
but its wave now has two wiggly parts
it really is in two places at once
so this is how you could sit in three
chairs at once and solve the problem of
the date at the movie theater
if you were at a quantum movie theater
rather than getting into an argument
about where to sit or just sitting where
neither of you wants to sit
you could both make your waves wiggle a
little bit in the front row
wiggle a little bit in the middle row
and wiggle a little bit in the back row
problem solved you'd simultaneously be
sitting
in three rows at once
but let's return to the quantum living
room when we last saw
our quantum particle it was sitting in a
mixed state
its wave was wiggling a little bit in
the tree and
a little bit on the couch we set this
wave up so that it's
70 percent on the couch and 30 percent
in the tree
and this is completely fine for a wave
to do
but then let's think about what happens
if we try to measure the particle's
position
when it's in this mixed state this is
like asking the particle
where it is and according to the laws of
quantum physics
only certain answers are allowed it's as
though
every time we make a measurement the
particle is forced
to fill out a quantum measurement form
with only
certain discrete check boxes when we ask
it where it is
the particle is not allowed to say i'm
part way between the couch and the tree
because it is not somewhere in the
middle rather
it's in both places at once when we make
this position measurement
the particle must return some answer
and that answer has to correspond to a
pure state of the question
that we asked in the case of this mixed
state
couch and tree particle only couch or
tree
are allowable answers this
is the crux of measurements in the
quantum world
since the answer must be either tree
or couch and it can't be somewhere in
between
we say the answers are quantized in
other words
when we ask this mixed particle where it
is
there's a 30 percent chance it will say
tree and there's a 70
chance it will say couch and no one has
any control
over which answer it will give it turns
out that the particle itself
doesn't even know which answer it will
give
and we the askers have no way of
determining
in advance which answer the particle
will give
the limitation here is not just a
limitation of our experiments or of our
measurements
the particle itself doesn't know what
it's going to say
until it has already become that answer
to my mind this is by far the weirdest
of all quantum phenomena
and it's weird enough that i'd like to
recap the situation
when a mixed state particle is forced by
our question to give us
an allowable answer it will suddenly
and uncontrollably be thrown into a pure
state of the type
the question demands when we ask the
question
we force the particle into a pure state
of that question type
but we have no way of knowing which
state that's going to be
then when the particle gives its answer
it becomes a pure state
and it will stay that way until
otherwise disturbed
in quantum language this sudden and
uncontrollable
snapping into a new pure state when a
measurement happens
that's what's referred to as wave
function collapse
now you might be asking yourself the
extremely important question
how do you know that wave function
collapse is really what's happening
the answer is we don't remember we can't
measure the wave function directly so we
can't
directly track it during these
measurements
however what we can say is that the
answers that come
out of the measurements that we take in
a laboratory
match the assumption of wave function
collapse
and that's why we continue to describe
what's called
orthodox quantum theory using that
assumption
or sometimes you'll hear it called a
postulate
but this is a piece of quantum theory
that could very well get
upgraded as we perform new experiments
experiments which
push the boundaries of our current
knowledge on this are being undertaken
by scientists around the world
for now i'll incorporate the assumption
of wave function collapse
into our discussions in this course
because it correctly
describes the results of all of the
experiments that have been done
so far so now back to our quantum living
room
where we just took a measurement on that
particle that was
in the mixed state the act of taking the
measurement
forced the particle to suddenly and
uncontrollably be thrown into a pure
state
of the type of measurement we were
taking as a direct result of our
measurement process
the particle suddenly snapped into a new
state so we see that a
big important principle in quantum
mechanics is that
observers disturb what they measure
let me give you a good analogy for just
how disturbing these measurements can be
imagine somebody trying to measure the
position of a crystal chandelier
blindfolded with a baseball bat
i'm willing to bet that you probably
wouldn't want someone walking into your
home
and figuring out where your crystal
chandelier is by blindfolding themselves
and swinging a baseball bat around
but it would work wouldn't it they could
use that method to find out the location
of the chandelier on the other hand
they would change the system in the
process
what we're encountering here is the
phenomenon that observers
disturb what they measure this issue
actually comes up in
every branch of science observers always
disturb what they measure
in science every time we make a
measurement in any context
we're always disturbing the system on
the scales that you're used to
it's a very weak disturbance for example
this video
is a type of measurement about what's
happening in the studio right now
does this measurement make disturbances
you bet it does
how does the camera capture its series
of images to make a video
the camera can capture images only when
the lights are on
photons are coming out of the light
sources then those photons are bouncing
off of me
and then heading back toward the camera
now for the photons to bounce off of me
they have to interact with me when the
photons hit me
they have to make some sort of
disturbance in order to get turned
around
and headed back toward the camera so
every single time we make any
measurement at all
we must disturb the system we're
measuring
we're used to cases where the
disturbance is minimal like the tiny
photons bouncing off of a large
macroscopic object but in quantum
mechanics the disturbance
is going to be a huge effect
let's return to our quantum living room
and find out the results of having taken
a position measurement on the mixed
state remember that when taking a
quantum measurement it's like the
particle has to fill out the results on
some quantum measurement form
and there are little check boxes and
only certain
answers are allowed other answers are
simply
forbidden let's say that when we asked
the particle where it is
it replied and snapped into the couch
state
that of course is a pure position state
not a mixture of two position states and
it is true although it's not the whole
truth
once we make the measurement and force
the particle to give up its mixed
state wave and become a pure state
after that we have no way of finding out
that it was ever in the mixed state
before
that information has been completely
lost
but from now on if we ask the particle
again where it
is right away the particle will say it's
on the couch
do you remember the movie theater you
really could sit in three chairs at once
that is until someone asked you which
chair you're sitting in
at that point you would be suddenly and
uncontrollably thrown
into one and only one seat and
all memory of your prior mixed state
would be erased a spinning coin is a
good analogy for the way in which these
measurements
force particular answers to come out and
for the fact that we don't have control
over which answer comes
up here's my quantum coin and just like
a regular coin it has
heads on one side and tails on the other
something that often comes up when you
make measurements of the quantum world
is that you'll end up asking questions
that aren't quite well defined until you
go to ask the question
so let's say for example i do this
[Music]
it came up tails that time and
i can go on measuring let's see what
happens if i flip the coin again
this time it came up heads i could keep
on measuring like this
this type of measurement is unambiguous
right i'm just
flipping a coin and then i take a
measurement by looking to see which side
is
up there's nothing strange going on here
but
what if i instead do this and i spin the
coin
is it heads or tails now while it's
spinning
while it's in the act of spinning it's
neither heads nor tails
but think of it like this a wave can do
whatever it wants to do it can go into a
state that's like being neither heads
nor tails now to answer the question
that i want to ask
in order to make a measurement that's
going to give me back
heads or tails i'm going to have to
disturb the spinning coin
system is it heads or tails
it's tails now notice that in this case
i have to
fundamentally change what's going on in
order for me to answer the question
is it heads or tails in this case the
question
was not well defined until i actually
asked the question
many measurements in quantum mechanics
end up being a little bit like this
we have to change the system in order to
get back
some allowable answer corresponding to
the type of question we
asked or more precisely what type of
measurement we took
and so that's frustrating this sort of
thing
makes us really uncomfortable in quantum
mechanics
nobody likes this it's doing one thing
and then the active measurement forces
it to do something
different it's heads by the way
but we can at least get an answer back
this is a good analogy for a lot of what
happens in quantum mechanical
measurements this spinning coin is also
a good analogy
for how probabilities can present
themselves in the quantum world
if i asked you in advance while the coin
is spinning
what percentage chance do you think i
would have of measuring heads if it's in
a really good spin
you'd say 50 right and you just knew
that
you didn't have to do any fancy
mathematics or detailed calculations to
get that
a lot of quantum measurements are like
that we may not be able to predict the
exact
outcome but we will be able to predict
how often particular answers
come up everything we've said about
quantum measurements so far
leads us to another big idea in quantum
physics and
perhaps you've already heard the phrase
that describes it the phrase is this
observer determines reality in fact
if you've done a google search on
anything quantum recently
chances are you then got a lot of ads
about how you can use quantum mechanics
to create your own reality
now this phrase observer determines
reality it actually does appear
in the literature on quantum mechanics
but it's much more
limited than it may sound at first in
fact
observer determined reality in our
example of the spinning coin
while the coin is spinning it's neither
heads nor tails
then in the act of making the
measurement to find out
whether it's heads or tails we forced
the coin into
a new state and it became either heads
or tails
this is the sense in which we the
observers
determined the reality for the coin but
it's probably much more accurate to say
that the observer
affected reality something similar
happened in our example of
sitting in three chairs at once in the
quantum movie theater
at first you really were in three places
at once
and that was all fine and well and good
until an observer walked up and
asked you which seat you were sitting in
at that point
you were thrown into only one chair
that's the sense in which your observer
determined your reality
but again it's probably more accurate to
say that the observer
affected your reality you certainly
couldn't use this to
create your own reality
that's because no one had control over
which seat you ultimately
snapped into you didn't control the
outcome
from your perspective it was like a roll
of the dice and
the observer or the person who asked you
the question
certainly didn't control the outcome
when asked which seat you were in
it's as though there had been a roll of
the dice and the outcome of that
roll decided which seat your wave would
now
snap into well
i hope you've enjoyed exploring some of
the fascinating ideas in quantum physics
with me today
if you are finding some of these ideas
to be a little
well odd i want you to know that you're
in good company at first
even einstein refused to believe that
probabilities or percent chances
underlie quantum mechanics until the
evidence convinced him otherwise
the kinds of strange physical phenomena
we encounter at the quantum level
take a while to get used to but i like
to keep in mind
michael faraday's famous words nothing
is too wonderful to be true
in the next lecture we'll delve more
into the consequences of these
probabilities
and we'll explore what schrodinger's cat
can teach us about taking measurements
i'll see you then
[Music]
you